[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 146 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
my name is Mack mando and I'm here as
always with my colleague Melanie Warwick
Melanie how are you doing hi Marc doing
great how are you doing I'm doing all
right
I'm doing very well very excited for
today's episode yes this week in
particular we're very excited to have
with us Jeff Dean who you may have heard
about him if you know a little bit about
Google and AI and tensorflow and GPUs
and big data systems and cats you may
have heard about him anyway all the
things that's a thing ok cool things
that come to computer systems hardware
and all that so we had a great
conversation with him and covered a lot
of these topics but part of the reason
why we have this interview this week is
because this week is deep learning in
dhaba which is happening out in
Stellenbosch in south africa and it's
bringing together researchers from
different countries within the African
continent to share their knowledge Jeff
Dean is going to be speaking there and
I'm also going to be there recording
some episodes so you know we wanted to
emphasize that a little bit we don't
actually get into the podcast about it
until later in but you can listen and
hear about what he's going to talk about
at the conference as always before we
get into that we are going to start out
with our cool things the week and we
will end with the question a week and we
have a special guest joining us to help
with the question of the week how do I
get data from IOT core to display in
real time on a web front-end yes and we
have Gabe West joining us today hi
friends so to start out the cool things
of the week something that I caught was
that Google has recently put into beta
data set search and so I caught this
actually because Ben hammer who is the
CTO at Kaggle had tweeted this out today
and specifically he was noting how you
know this helps to index metadata on
open datasets and should be pretty
useful for people who are researchers
and those that are curious about public
datasets and wanting to explore them so
we'll include the link to it but it's
pretty much a search tool it's a Google
search tool just specifically on
datasets awesome I wanted to talk about
this really cool thing I like to which
is we are expanding our public datasets
for geospatial and ml based analytics so
you may have heard back at cloud next we
announced an additional five petabytes
of bigquery storage available for public
datasets in the blog post will link to
in the show notes
we also talked about that this
additional storage will also be
available for the next five years which
is also really cool since next though we
have on-boarded seven new data sets that
define boundaries in the United States
by parameters such as zip code and
things like that basically to support
geospatial queries so we have a whole
bunch of new data in there for you to do
dear special stuff to do email based
analytics to use the newer model
toolkits that are available now in
bigquery and if you want take advantage
of any of those make sure you head over
to the Google cloud platform marketplace
there's a datasets filter you can go
into and at last look it looks like we
have about a hundred and one different
public datasets for you to play with on
bigquery and you can do up to a terabyte
of querying on bigquery for free which
is also pretty amazing
per month another thing we wanted to
mention again referencing Kaggle and
also Google ai is that there's a new
challenge through kaggle Google AI has
posted specifically to encourage the
users and the cacklers out there to
develop models that are more robust to
blindspots that exist in datasets we've
talked about this in the past see many
people discuss you know machine learning
bias and fairness in particular and that
you know really stems from the data
itself and how the data can really be
biased in what you've gathered and how
that can then influence the model that's
built so their challenge is specifically
to help identify techniques and
approaches to account for that and to
make the model more robust this
challenge in particular is set to run
into stages they've got the information
on the website that will keep a link in
too but it's going to wrap up around the
time of nips that's later this year
December and so you can check that out
and experiment excellent I also want to
mention that we were checking out the
top 100 podcasts in tech recently on
iTunes and we're in it
[Music]
which is kind of cool so thank you very
much to everyone who's been listening
people who have rated us on iTunes and
basically have supported the podcast
that's a really nice little thing yes
and last but not least if you want to
know what makes TP use fine tuned for
deep learning we've got a blog post that
we're going to share that you can look
into this and you know we figured this
is especially relevant for today's
episode but it helps to step you through
what neural nets are it helps step you
through how to use work as well as in
comparison to CPUs and you see these
nice graphics that do a good job in
terms of stepping you through what that
looks like visually nice and some
pricing information at the bottom to
ankle alright mark I think we should go
ahead and get into it we've got a great
interview now with Jeff let's go talk to
your buddy Jeff yeah we play cards we're
thrilled today to have with us Jeff Dean
who is heading up Google ai thank you
Jeff for joining us thanks very much for
having me so Jeff I mean I know a lot of
people know who you are but we always
ask all of the people who come on the
show to tell a little bit about
themselves what your background is what
you do sure so at the moment I am
leading google's AI vision internally we
know that as Google research machine
intelligence but externally we kind of
used Google AI sometimes depending on
who were talking to and so that
organization does lots of different
kinds of computer science research we do
fundamental research trying to create
new algorithms new techniques to solve
problems we do a fair amount of work
with Google product areas to work with
you know interesting research problems
in the context of products and get sort
of our research out into the Google
products that everyone knows and loves
and uses we also have been doing a bit
more work on sort of systems
infrastructure for enabling our research
but then also creating tools that enable
internal developers at Google but also
external developers when we open source
things so tensorflow for example came
out of our group and is a popular
machine learning toolkit we feel like
that's a good way to really broaden the
impact of the research that we're doing
is to make it easy for people to then
build on the work that we're doing and
have good tools available and then the
fourth kind of thing that we generally
do is try to find new areas that Google
currently work in where we think our
research can make a big impact so we've
been doing a lot of work on sort of
machine learning for healthcare machine
learning for robotics because we think
those are kind of new emerging areas
where machine learning and our research
will make a big difference in terms of
the work that your team is doing what
does it mean for you and what does it
look like for you now that because I
know this is a fairly new position to a
degree that you're in as the lead of
Google AI this year right yes yes I took
on this role in III guess late March
early April and basically my goal is to
inspire our great researchers to do
great research and to tackle the
important ambitious problems that I
think we should be working on I spend
Monday's coding oh wow and with my
colleague Sanjay Ghemawat who I've been
working with for many years I kind of
probably have four or five other
projects that I'm involved in an actual
technical level where I go to the weekly
meetings and make sort of technical
suggestions and so on and then the rest
of my time is spent kind of trying to
steer a reasonably large organisation to
do the right things and to make sure
that we're focused on the right problems
and have impact well so I'm curious what
do you code in I'm mostly C++ Oh fun so
I like asking these questions for people
who work in AI and I'm out because we
get varying answers
what does AI mean to you it means
basically being able to have computer
systems that can solve problems that you
would think of as requiring human
intelligence I think that's actually the
most concise answer we've ever gotten
yeah pretty straightforward well in
terms of the work that you do what do
you think are some of the biggest
challenges that you are up against
really it's an exciting time to be in
the field the computer science research
and machine learning research because
there's an explosion of interest in this
field as in the last maybe seven or
eight years collectively as a research
community we've really pushed forward
what computers can do I think this is
sort of most striking in the computer
vision field we're essentially using
deep learning models for computer vision
has suddenly transformed computers from
not being able to see very well to now
actually be able to see and if you think
about the impact on the world that that
will have or and is already having you
know that's transformative suddenly you
can have automated machines able to
perceive the world around
able to sort of understand what they're
looking at and that has huge
implications for you know general
computer vision so it's a key enabler
for a lot of the experience that google
photos provides Google users like we can
understand that's a picture of a doorman
and that's the mountain but it also
means transformative things in
healthcare so tons and tons of medical
imaging related problems now are sort of
tackle able with automated machine
learning algorithms and assisting sort
of medical professionals in that way
robotics it's very clear if you want to
build a robot it's very helpful if the
robot can see yes that has big
implications and I think we're making
significant progress in other fields
related to machine learning so things
like natural language understanding and
speech recognition you've seen
tremendous advances over the last you
know six or seven years and that really
means there's all these opportunities
about how we should be using these new
capabilities to affect the world right
to make it a better place to melk build
new things that we couldn't build before
and I think that's the excitement and
the flood of interest in studying this
field how do people do research in this
field how can more people enter this
field and do research so we spoke
earlier this year with dr. Feifei leave
around cloud AI we spoke not too long
ago with Riya had sell out of deepmind
and talked about some of the robotics
research that they're doing how does
brain and Google AI collaborate with the
different groups right so we actually
have strong collaborations across all of
Google and even across all of alphabet
in many areas and so with cloudy I for
example many of the sort of things that
they are bringing to market started as
research projects in the Google AI
research division and we're now
collaborating closely to bring things
like the auto ml research that was
started into products like cloud auto ml
where now customers who have computer
vision or other kinds of problems that
maybe don't have sophisticated machine
learning developers on staff but want to
be able to take advantage of the machine
learning sort of capabilities that now
exist we have
systems that can automatically train and
learn to solve new problems that a
customer might have they might have
pictures of broken parts on their
assembly line and not broken parts and
they want to be able to distinguish and
they can essentially just upload those
images and get a trained model that
helps them with that particular task
even without having sort of a masters
level machine learning expert on staff
makes sense I know one of your areas of
passion in particular and where you've
had a significant impact especially is
around the tensor processing units that
GPUs what helped drive or inspire the
initial development of GPUs and I know
you've had this conversation before but
you know especially from like your
experience as you were coming along and
getting into technology to begin with
like how did that come about for you
right so I've always been interested in
how can computers solve interesting
problems and one interesting way of
doing that is to bring more computation
to bear on problems that you can then
use more sophisticated algorithms or you
can use you know larger data sets to
derive better insights and so having
more computation is generally a good
thing in computing and around the time
of maybe 2011 2012 when the Google brain
project that I co-founded was just
getting started we started to
collaborate with a number of different
product teams at Google to use deep
learning and some of the products and
the ones we collaborated with most
closely with were the speech recognition
team to replace kind of the older style
machine learning model that they were
using for speech recognition with a a
deep learning based model for the
acoustic portion of it another part of
the model that goes from a very small
audio recording to a part of a word is
it or breaths yeah and then there was
another model that we didn't focus on
initially kind of after that stage of
the processing but replacing the the
acoustic model with a deep learning
based acoustic model gave a lot of gains
in recognition accuracy and so we could
tell that as speech recognition gets
better people are going to use it more
and more and so I started to do some
back of the envelope calculations of
like well what happens if people start
talking to their phone three minutes a
day
right because they're gonna draft all
their emails with speech or something
and at the time we had you know just
lots and lots of CPUs in our data center
and if you looked at how much
computation that would be required if
100 million of our users started to do
that that was actually kind of daunting
and scary we would have to centrally
double the computing footprint of Google
just to support like a slightly better
speech recognition model for modest
fraction of our users seems legit
yeah so it seems a little scary yeah but
it's clear we want to deploy that to our
users because the gains in recognition
accuracy are actually quite significant
and so we started to look at what could
we do for these kinds of deep learning
models that would be more
computationally efficient and there are
two really nice properties that deep
learning models have so first they are
very tolerant of reduced precision so
essentially if you do the Precision's to
like one decimal digit of accuracy
that's actually perfectly fine for these
models you don't need six or seven
digits of precision like you would in
floating-point computations or even more
in double computations and the second
property they have is that all the
algorithms are made up of like different
compositions of handful of building
blocks essentially matrix multiplies
vector dot products linear algebra style
operations so if you can build hardware
that is only designed to accelerate low
precision linear algebra you're golden
and that enables you to vend really
tailor the hardware to do only that it
doesn't need to do twisty branch easy
c++ code of all kinds of arbitrary
things pointer dereferences just low
precision linear algebra then suddenly
you can rethink how you would completely
design a computer to do only that since
it's it's focused and exactly what it is
it can do does that mean there are
certain applications that are better or
worse for a TPU that you might use
something else for or how does that work
right so that this is one of the
double-edged sword the specialization is
if you over specialize then it's not
generally applicable but if you make
something very generally applicable then
it doesn't get all the performance
benefits you could get from
specialization and we actually chose I
think a pretty good balance for TPU
they're essentially designed to
accelerate exactly the kinds of
operations you find in deep learning
models so they're not general
purpose sort of computational devices
but they are not tailored to a
particular model they're tailored to all
the kinds of operations you generally
find in deep learning models and so you
can run vision models you own them you
can run speech models you can run
recurrent language models the first TPU
TPU v1 was targeted at only inference
where you actually need even less
precision than the training process and
that was our most pressing problem that
was how we could get the speech
recognition model out to the world
without doubling Google's data center
footprint and then the second GPU was
really both was targeted at both
training and inference and the reason we
didn't bite that off first was that
training is a much more complex hardware
design problem because for inference
usually you can design things so that a
single model will fit on one chip and if
you need more capacity you just kind of
stamp out lots of copies of that that
system and put a lot of boards and a lot
of computers and all of a sudden you
have lots of speech recognition capacity
for training it's very unlikely for
large models you can get a single chip
to be fast enough to train a model like
very fast and what you really want in
training is fast turnaround for machine
learning experiments or huge scalability
so you can train very large models on
very large data sets very quickly and be
able to iterate from a machine learning
research perspective or a deployed
system you know you might want to
retrain your model every 10 minutes
because your data changes there it's not
just a chip design problem it's actually
a whole computer system it's more like a
supercomputer design problem where you
have the chips and then you have some
complicated interconnect that connects
them together you have cooling issues
for how to cool this giant thing it's
made up of multiple racks and so that's
why we didn't bite that off in the first
system but chose to wait till the second
iteration of the GPU designed to tackle
training as well and you announced this
year at version 3 FTP use as well yes
and am i right and remembering that the
cooling system it's now liquid yeah
turns out yeah it is fancy
anytime you you mix computers in water
it's always exciting
so the TPU v3 which is under our
announced it
Google i/o in May of 2018 essentially
got water cooling so board has for these
chips on it and the water cooling kind
of goes to the surface of these chips
and takes excess heat away and the
largest footprint deployment we call
these things pods the TPU v2 pods were
essentially made up of 64 of those
devices 256 TPU v2 chips and the pod
scale for the TPU v3 is much larger so
we have about 8 times as much
computation in the TPU v3 pod as we did
in the TPU v2 pod I know a couple of the
people on your team was specifically
running a Stanford on bench on it and
they were showing the differences in
terms of its performance like right now
all it's going in my head right now is
the image net but I gotta pitch please
Don bench is a new machine learning
benchmark set up by a research group at
Stanford the dawn research group that is
designed to look at a variety of
different kinds of machine learning
problems both training and inference and
measures a few different metrics so one
of them is for particular machine
learning problem how quickly can you get
to a certain level of accuracy that is
sort of a good level of accuracy for
that problem I'm one of them is a image
net processing benchmark or you have to
get to 76 percent top on accuracy and
this is classifying images very much
like that you get a color image you have
to classify it into one of a thousand
categories it's actually pretty hard
human error rate in top one accuracy is
about 5 percent so uh so because it's
got like 40 breeds of dogs and you'll be
able to distinguish and so I'm guessing
the TV use did pretty ok yeah so the TP
use took the top three spots in the
overall time metric with pods and then
also the top two spots I believe in the
cost using public cloud computing
resources cool well what do you enjoy
most about working with these chips and
working with the parallel processing I
actually have been excited about
parallel processing for quite some time
ever since I took a course my senior
year at University of Minnesota on
parallel processing and at the time I
was really excited about that because I
felt like more computation was the
answer to solving
more problems and this was kind of
during the first wave of excitement
about neural nets that happened in the
late 80s and early 90s when new
algorithms were developed and was first
surfacing as like a potentially
interesting way to tackle some difficult
problems and at that time basically
neural nets could get interesting
results on very toy size problems but
not sort of scale to really interesting
problems and so there was a wave of
excitement about this but then in this
wave of excitement I kind of felt like
more computation was going to be helpful
for letting us tackle bigger problems
and so I did an undergrad thesis working
with the professor who taught parallel
and distributed computing class I took
sort of did an independent thesis on
parallel training of neural nets and so
I felt like if we could take the 64
processor machine we had in the
department and you know apply parallel
methods to it we could get you know
factor 60 more compute applied to these
things and then we could scale up and
tackle bigger problems in retrospect we
needed like a million times more
computation not 16mm and so if you
essentially just wait it out with
Moore's law at least until about five or
ten years ago when Moore's law
significantly slowed down but before
that you know the previous 25 years 40
years even we were getting these
consistent you know 2x performance
improvement every two years you just
wait long enough and all of a sudden
voilá million times as much compute and
you're golden and that's sort of what
started to happen in like 2008-2009 we
suddenly had enough compute initially
using GPU cards which were designed for
gaming but obviously have turned out to
be quite useful for training deep
learning models because a lot of the
acceleration you want to do for graphics
processing turns out to be amenable to
to training deep learning models and so
that was when people start in the
academic community started to really see
that we were starting to get interesting
results on real problems using knowlins
yeah so there was kind of excitement
started to build back up what was one of
the hardest parts in your career it
wasn't like AI was well accepted for
many many years when you were studying
between then and 2006 really right so
what was some of the hardest moments in
terms of pursuing this interest pursuing
this
yeah I actually kind of come at this as
a computer general computer systems
person so I like to view the kind of
lens I bring to problems is there's an
interesting problem let's figure out how
we can build a computer system to tackle
that problem often involving you know
either kind of good abstractions for
expressing computations we want to
perform or using large amounts of
computation and figure out how to
parallelize or distribute computation
across lots of machines so that we can
sort of scale up the computation so
although I was doing work as an
undergrad on this parallel training of
neural ads I was coming at it from the
perspective of how can we build a
computer system to do this and then I
sort of started to get back interested
in machine learning in like 2011 when I
happened to bump into Andrew Inge in a
micro kitchen I was gonna say the story
goes you were in a micro good job yes so
I knew him a little bit and so I said
what are you doing here he's like go on
spending a day we at Google X and I
haven't quite figured out what I'm doing
here yet but you know my students at
Stanford are starting to like see what
kinds of problems can be solved with
rollouts and they're getting pretty good
results I'm like oh really that's pretty
cool I did a bit of work on neural nets
and the undergrad I said they're really
working now and he's like yeah so I said
we should train really big no that's and
so that was sort of the genesis of how
we decided to form the Google brain
project along with Greg Corrado and we
basically at that time didn't have
accelerators or data centers but we said
we have a lot of computers let's figure
out how to make a computer system train
really big neural nets love using CPUs
and so like is that the moment where you
were like this is gonna be a really big
thing did you think it then I did feel
like you know once we kind of did a
little bit more work maybe another month
of dabbling then it seemed like hey we
can actually tackle problems using
neural nets that people have felt like
they're the right abstraction for a long
time but maybe they would suddenly start
to work in real problems if we could
apply lots of computation and so that's
really been what a lot of my focus has
been on the last you know six or seven
years is how can we bring lots of
computation to the problems
you want to tackle with machine learning
and in particular deep learning so we're
recording this the day after the neural
information processing systems
conference sold out in like 11 minutes
and so many seconds 48 I think 48
minutes and 48 seconds using this as an
example there's a lot of excitement
clearly in this field how do you feel
about all this excitement you know there
is a fair amount of hype but on the
other hand the hype some of it is
actually justified because we're now
actually able to build systems that can
solve problems we couldn't solve five or
ten years ago I mentioned computer
vision speech recognition as advanced
tremendously translation as a chanst
many applications of these sorts of
things have shown real improvements or
new capabilities in what computers can
do so I think that's part of why people
are excited many many people want to
enter the field so you see enrollment in
machine learning classes undergraduate
and graduate levels just going through
the roof you see more and more people
attending the major machine learning
conferences you see the number of
research papers on archive actually
growing at a faster exponential rate
than Moore's Law over the last seven or
eight years it's quite remarkable and
you know I think it's important to
temper people's expectations who think
we're gonna have super intelligent
things that can solve problems general
problems that humans can't solve in the
next you know six months that's kind of
the one level of hype that's clearly not
justified but it's also important to
recognize that computers can now see
that's a pretty big deal and that has
major implications across a bunch of
different areas you know Google or an
alphabet or working on autonomous cars
clearly computer vision and perception
is an important component of making safe
autonomous cars robotics machine
learning for medical imaging machine
learning for other medical applications
healthcare applications these are going
to transform you know major problems in
in the world and that's good that's why
there's hype it's important to tamp down
excessive hype but das to say that there
shouldn't be any hype because I think we
are making significant advances and what
computers can do any applications in
particular that you've seen that you
feel like
get a lot of attention but are pretty
impactful yeah I mean I think there's a
realization that I've come to from
looking at a few different problems
researchers in our group have tackled
and other work that's going on where in
many scientific problems there are for
example traditional high performance
computing based simulations of some
property some scientific thing maybe
you're simulating chemical interactions
at a very fine grained level how do the
electrons flow around and what what
properties is that have or maybe you're
simulating earthquake faults and you
have a very detailed sort of physics
based model of how slippage in
earthquake faults happens and often
these computational models are very very
expensive computationally so you know
you run one chemical through your
simulator and an hour later you get
information about you know the quantum
properties of this this chemical or what
binds to Wyatt or things like that and
you can actually use that simulator as a
teacher and so if you have a really
expensive scientific simulator often you
can train and roll that to do what that
simulator does completely end down
you've take the inputs you would have
fed to the simulator and you get the
outputs and you run a bunch of examples
through the simulator now you have a
training set for Nolan and in a few
different domains we've actually seen
people do this and in for example in the
quantum chemistry domain George Dahl and
others in our research group worked with
some chemists at different universities
and took the simulator they were using
trained in and all that to do it and now
they can't distinguish the accuracy
versus the original sort of HPC style
simulator but the tool is three hundred
thousand times faster Wow and anytime
you take your tool and you make it 300
thousand times faster that just
transforms how you would do science
right you can imagine I'm gonna go make
coffee
let me screen a hundred million
molecules and then when I come back I'll
look at the ten thousand that are most
interesting and that same thing happened
with Brendan Meade who was a visiting
Harvard faculty member who visited our
group in Cambridge for a year and did a
bunch of work on earthquake fault
simulation he relayed that in work he'd
just done before he came to visit us
that he'd replaced the earthquake fault
simulation inner loop with kind of the
world's lamest neural that it was
you know four layers of ten neurons each
and all of a sudden the thing was like
between ten and a hundred thousand times
faster the difference in accuracy so I
think that's a good lens to look at you
know are you doing scientific computing
or simulation of some sort can you then
training or a lot to do an approximation
of that that is you know quite likely to
be accurate if you give it enough
training data now I'm just thinking
about work with hands and so now I'm
like if you can get that kind of
performance for that level of simulation
you can do some really interesting
things right yeah and I think I saw you
speak about this too that you're using
neural nets as well to help with
improving the actual performance of the
systems themselves there's a big
opportunity in general computer systems
so if you think about what's at the
heart of operating systems or compilers
or storage systems or other computer
systems you know they're generally laden
with kind of handwritten heuristics you
know which process should the operating
system schedule next out of the ready
processes that are available or for a
compiler should it you know emit code
with this loop net ordering or this loop
ordering or which you know variable
should its build a memory when it can't
fit them all in registers and in many
cases I believe these are actually
learning problems and so the heuristics
that people tend to handwrite have to
work well in the general case and they
can't really be developed in such a way
that they completely adapt to how the
system is being used so to give you an
example in our BigTable storage system
you know this is essentially a key value
store and client requests come in to
BigTable servers and they can request
that certain data be read from different
tables and when that happens the
BigTable server decides to put it in a
name memory cache so that if that data
is needed again then you know you have
it in the cache you don't have to go to
disk and and fetch it and if you look
lots of information is available at the
time you make the decision to read the
data from disk we know for example the
internal user group of the job that's
running that process that requested the
data we know maybe the job name that
requested this and you would never write
a heuristic so a lot of the processing
is from sequential MapReduce style
processing job
that are gonna read the data once never
use it again until like an hour later
when a similar MapReduce starts up but
you don't really want to insert that in
the cache because you're not going to
get any reuse sort of immediately but
you would never write a heuristic in the
middle of your BigTable server that says
you know if job name starts with
MapReduce - you know don't insert in the
cache but if you look at what a learning
heuristic could do it would pretty
quickly learn the pattern that these
jobs that seem to start with MapReduce -
never seemed to reuse the data inserting
the cache so I'm just not going to
insert and I think there's huge
potential for the thousands and
thousands and thousands of heuristics in
computer systems to really mostly be
learned and adapt to how they're
actually being used that's wonderful and
exciting - to think about the ways that
this could be improved upon I feel like
there's so many things I want to ask you
and we definitely are gonna be limited
on time so I want to make sure it makes
some space and time for the fact that
you're gonna be in South Africa when we
release this and specifically you're
there to speak at a deepening a dhaba
that's taking place outside of Cape Town
so can you tell us a little bit about
how you're involved in this the the
conference itself and and what you're
gonna be speaking about sure so I'm
gonna give a talk on solving challenging
problems in the world with deep learning
or something nice and actually the way
it's framed is around the National
Academy of Engineering put out in 2008 a
list of important problems for the
engineering community writ large to work
on in the 21st century and it's like a
list of 14 different areas things like
you know improve medical informatics
develop better drugs improve solar
energy output and if you look at them I
actually think machine learning will be
useful for tackling smaller or larger
pieces of all of those different things
so the talk is framed a bit as like hey
here's some interesting work that we've
done that is part of the way towards
solving some of these grand challenge
kind of areas nice and so the deep
learning in dhaba I think is a really
exciting event it's a gathering of I
think it's about four or five hundred
people from around mostly the African
continent from different countries and
really there's a burgeoning and exciting
community in Africa that is excited
about using machine learning and doing
machine learning research using machine
learning to tackle problems
countries in Africa and around the world
and I think this is really exciting to
see this swelling of a research
community in in Africa as well as the
rest of the world so I'm excited to go
take part of Matt I actually lived in
Uganda Somalia I was a kid oh wow cool
so I just care deeply about it matters a
lot to you to be able to participate and
to see and grow this group fantastic I
know too that brain has expanded into
Ghana and there's an outfit that's being
led by Mustapha sis who we at some point
hopefully will get to come on the
podcast as well because I've met him and
he's wonderful I know he's great and I
know they're off the ground and running
as we speak are there you know other
groups that you're looking to grow or
other offices that you're looking to
spin up that you can even speak about or
is that something we can't talk about
right now we're very excited about the
Ghana office like we're in the final
throes of renovating the office space
and we've hired a bunch of people for
the office that I think is going to be a
great addition to our global research
organization they're going to do
fantastic work in both basic machine
learning research looking at some sort
of interesting applied problems that are
particular to Ghana and the rest of
Africa yeah I think it's gonna be great
I love Mustafa
he's a wonderful leader and it's great
that we have him in the office he's a
wonderful person out there the other
thing I wanted to ask you or a couple
other things so looking forward to deep
learning a dhaba anybody who's out there
who you know has interests there'll be
resources will provide on the shownotes
the last couple things I want to make
sure we touch on before we let you go
love to know what is one of the best
pieces of advice that you've received in
your career I don't know if it's a
specific piece of advice that I've
received but an observation I've made
throughout my career is that really good
way to do interesting things is to
partner with people who know things that
you don't and I often find that working
on projects with like three or four
people where you each have kind of
different kinds of expertise and
collectively you kind of come together
to tackle some some interesting problem
that none of you could solve
individually but collectively you can
because you have the full totality of
techniques or can develop them and the
reason that's really important is it's a
good way to continuously learn new
things even after you get out of school
you know I think when you're in
undergraduate or a graduate school or
whatever you're obviously learning
things but it's important to kind of
continue to learn things and pick up new
ideas and sort of stimulate your brain
and this is a really good way to do that
and then you kind of go off that project
and go onto a different project and some
of the other people's expertise is kind
of rubbed off as a as a sheen on you and
you can now at least look at problems
through the lens of the kinds of
expertise they have and say oh yeah that
looks a lot like this I know the
questions to ask or the right approach
to take in tackling this even if that's
not your sort of formal background yes
definitely
you'd mentioned about Moore's Law and
the amount of research that's coming out
and papers in particular how do you keep
up on the resources and the research and
all that yeah I mean again I think this
is something we're surrounding yourself
with people who know things that you
don't is a really good way because if
you have a good network of people that
you interact with they can partly be
your eyes and ears and look out for
interesting things in their sort of area
focus and say oh yeah that's kind of
interesting someone told me about this
today and you can kind of start to
connect the dots between different areas
and see you know the potential for a
technique developed over here how it
might be used over here or how it might
combine well with some other technique
and really build on each other so I
think it's very hard to keep up with
everything so you need to sort of
collectively find some things you really
do follow yourself and then get a
cursory level of information about other
things one thing I've observed is that a
lot of people really really deeply read
a research paper and I think that's
important sometimes but it's kind of the
wrong approach for general learning I
think you'd be much better served to
take the time to read a hundred
abstracts of a hundred different papers
and sort of understand the highest level
concept that they each have because you
could always go read that thing in more
detail if you need to find out more
about it but being able to have those
hundred pieces of information of like oh
yeah that's a technique that's the thing
we can kind of do something like that
that's how you really start to connect
the dots and
make connections across fields or across
different problems nice any specific
public research you've heard of very
recently that you're like specifically
comes to your mind that you're like this
is exciting to me or well I think the
general idea of having computers that
can automatically do experiments and
then measure the results of those and
then sort of continuously absorb the
results of a first set of experiments
and then generate new experiments so all
of the neural architecture search work
or the auto ml work that our group has
been doing a lot of the reinforcement
learning based work that is showing
promise in solving games like go or
opening our Kadota I think all these
things kind of point at that general
direction of having computers they can
automatically explore you know different
approaches to solving problems is going
to be important because a computer can
run fifty thousand experiments and
whereas a human runs fifty looks at the
results and then in figures out what are
the next fifty to run yep okay and then
the other question I want to ask you out
of all the interviews you've ever done
what question do you wish people would
ask you yeah I will tell you one
interesting thing that some people don't
know so I actually moved around a lot as
a kid I went to eleven schools in 12
years and I think that's a lot of
schools that is a lot of schools yes
like Oh new year new school you learn
how to make a lot of friends sure yeah I
mean I think it was pretty helpful for
me because it let me live in lots of
different places lots of different kinds
of environments everywhere from Hawaii
Boston Uganda Boston Arkansas Hawaii
Minnesota Somalia Atlanta Geneva Seattle
and the Bay Area and you must not be
open-minded at all I think it does help
because you can find really great
aspects of any of those places and I
think that's a good perspective
fantastic before we wrap up any
resources you want to recommend to our
listeners for people who aren't get into
deep learning if you use Google brain
just ml research you know I'm asked this
question a lot and a lot of it depends
on the kind of level of expertise
someone already has these I think I
don't have a single answer but I
recommend you know there's lots of good
blogs out there Chris all's blog and the
distill dot pub journal that he started
with Shawn Carter are really good
expositions for
people with a certain level expertise I
think there's things like the machine
learning crash course that Google put
out there's lots of courses on Udacity
and Coursera for different levels of
expertise the deep learning textbook
that Ian Goodfellow
yoshua bengio and Aaron Carville put out
is a very good one there's lots of
material targeted at sort of people with
less advanced math skills for like high
school students and middle school
students even so there's just a wealth
of information out there and it's really
great that the community is producing so
much introductory material and more
advanced material for everyone excellent
great well we did cover the fact that
you're speaking at deep learning in Java
anything else that you wanted to mention
before we let you go no I'm just really
excited thanks for having me and thanks
for the conversation thank you so much
for coming on yeah sure thank you again
Jeff it was really great to just to get
into all the things and one of the many
things that I really appreciated from
that was hearing that he's still codes
yeah he's like this is my day Monday I
could yeah that is when I will code so
it's hard to do that as you become more
senior to make that type of space in
your life so anyways thank you yeah all
right
question of the week so we have our
wonderful friend here gay hey so gay we
have a wonderful question for you
because we know you do stuff we an IOT
core I'm ready if I have an IOT core
thing how do I get my data from IOT core
to display in real time on a web
front-end if you've done something like
this I have recently so anyone that's
worked in IOT knows there's a bajillion
different ways to do this there's
different classes of devices or
different protocols those different
everything so there's how many grains of
sand on a beach are there that's how
many ways are to do this the way that we
did it as kind of our golden path that
cloud next in 2018 we built an entire
end and app on stage there are five of
us so we went from devices we use
Raspberry Pi with some sensors that we
did measuring heart rate and that will
communicate with mqtt is the protocol
that we use that IOT core understands
how to receive so you can send your
telemetry data from your devices to IOT
core from IOT core it gets bridged all
of your telemetry data becomes events
and cloud pub/sub which is our event
stream manager from cloud pub/sub you
can trigger cloud functions which we did
to pull the telemetry data out of
pub/sub and put it into our data
warehouse which was cloud fire store we
firestore because it's a no sequel
database it's super low latency and it
has a special sauce which is as a push
mechanism so that front-end apps can
register for a callback when any data
changes in the database so for real-time
applications this is huge
so our front-end was an angular app that
we wrote that subscribe to this callback
from fire store that pulls it in and
draws our heart rates on a graph so and
end it was device up to IOT core which
gets bridge into cloud pub/sub hub sype
had a cloud function that pulls from it
shoves it into cloud fire store our fire
store triggered with its callback into
an angular app nice yeah wow that's
pretty cool don't worry times quickly I
know I can't I did it once I was good
enough right that way if people is there
like a public sample or anything that
people can actually go and have a look
at yeah so the easiest way to find it is
going to be if on YouTube you do a
search for building IOT applications on
Google Cloud the only one on there
you'll find our video from the
conference and in the links in the
description is linked to the github with
all of our code awesome well great well
thanks Gabriel preciate you coming on
let's do the question of the week thanks
for having me all right mark where you
gonna be what am i doing what you doing
what you know so when this comes out I
will be in Tokyo yes you well getting
ready for Tokyo next so pretty excited
about that gonna be talking there about
it gonna is talking some gaming people
and stuff so if you're in town come say
hi what are you up to and I will be and
still am but I think I probably said
that a lot at this point but I will be
there doing some interviews and then you
and I will both be and strange leap at
the end of the month yeah which is gonna
be really good Gabe you going anywhere
special in next month or so I am doing a
European trip I'm doing London Paris
Barcelona for a series of conferences
that sounds difficult conferences you go
to so London is cloud next yep which is
our kind of next iteration of our series
and then Paris is visiting teammates
because I have a weird kind of five days
I don't want to fly back and forth to
Europe and Barcelona is the big IOT
conference IOT solutions World Congress
which is kind of the big european iot
conference nice yeah well have a good
trip thanks mark I think that's it for
us this week yes so Melanie and Gabe
thanks for joining us for yet another
week on the podcast thank you thanks and
thank you all for listening and we'll
see you all next week
[Music]
[Music]